das ist wirklich eine ziemlich verrückte
vorstellung existieren schwarze löcher
eigentlich nur für einen
sekundenbruchteil und explodieren dann
sofort wieder als weiße löcher aber
wieso finden wir dann immer mehr
schwarze löcher und die sind dann auch
noch milliarden jahre alt es ist ganz
einfach ein stein lässt grüßen ein
effekt der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie wieso weshalb warum
jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt ist es
gar nicht so abwegig wir gehen ja davon
aus dass in einem schwarzen loch eine
singularität existiert die komplette
materie die in das schwarze loch stürzt
ist auf einen punkt konzentriert dieser
punkt ist eine unglaubliche gravitation
auf seine umgebung aus sie ist so stark
dass sogar licht in diesem punkt stürzt
das ist die ursache für den
ereignishorizont hinter dieser grenze
kann nichts dem schwarzen noch
entfliehen
wenn aber die gravitation dort so stark
ist dann kommt sie auch raum und zeit
und vor allem die zeit die interessiert
uns jetzt mit der gravitation ist es ja
wie mit der lichtgeschwindigkeit wir
kennen es ja von hohen geschwindigkeiten
um so schneller ich reise desto
langsamer vergeht die zeit an bord
während also bei mir nur ein jahr
vergeht sind es auf der erde zum
beispiel 1000 jahre
ich bin in die zukunft gereist und
genauso verhält es sich mit großen
massen sie haben den gleichen effekt wie
lichtgeschwindigkeit in ihrer nähe
vergeht die zeit viel langsamer was im
schwarzen loch einen sekundenbruchteil
ist könnte außerhalb genau eine ewigkeit
sein
das ganze nennt sich zeit delegation
werden wir in einem schwarzen loch und
können nach draußen sehen würde dort
alles im flug passieren einen
augenzwinkern und schon ja haye ist
unsere milchstraße entstanden und die
menschheit hat schon ein paar kriege
geführt und ist auf dem mond gelandet
das video übrigens zur einfach erklärten
speziellen und allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie werde ich am ende
verlinken
moment dann wären sämtliche schwarzen
löcher nur eine erscheinung für
sekundenbruchteile und was dann
jetzt kommt noch etwas sehr
verblüffendes der quanten rückprall das
quanten bauens das heißt das schwarze
loch würde in der sekunde in der es
entsteht wieder explodieren und alles
ines gestürzte wieder auswerfen
es wäre ein weißes loch der prozess
würde sich wieder umkehren aber warum
haben wir das dann noch nie beobachtet
ganz einfach der sekundenbruchteil ist
noch nicht vorbei doch abhängig von der
masse könnte es schon bald die ersten
explodierenden schwarzen löcher aus der
frühzeit des universums geben und
vielleicht haben wir sie schon
beobachtet und für supernovae gehalten
eines ist jedoch noch sag ich mal
irritierender dieser theorie liegt die
schleifen quantengravitation zugrunde
und theoretischer physiker haben
durchgerechnet was dann passieren würde
bei ihnen kollabierte allerdings nicht
ein einzelner stern sondern gleich das
ganze universum moment da war doch was
urknall empfehlen wir ein explodierendes
weißes loch und die hintergrundstrahlung
das licht dieses weißen loches wahnsinn
wir sind hier noch ganz am anfang der
forschung sobald es etwas neues gibt der
farbe ist wie immer natürlich hier bei
pixum mir einfach dafür ihr genau ein
abo aufs auge drücken und das auf die
glocke nicht vergessen dann verpasst er
kein video mehr hier geht es da zur
relativitätstheorie einfach erklärt und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran